[Music]
last weekend on the occasion of the
virtual comic-con experience in brazil
many fans thought there could be a first
trailer for universal's monster
spectacle
godzilla vs kong unfortunately again to
no avail
but even if a full trailer has not yet
been published
fans can still look forward to a few
seconds of video material and get a
first impression
you can't see a direct face-off of the
giants yet but at least you can see one
in chains wearing a metal collar
while the other is swimming ominously in
the sea since there is no detailed
information about the story up to now
the question remains whether the giant
gorilla in the short video is already
back in human civilization
it figures that the two monsters will
somehow meet and that they might also
get company from other colossal
companions
the whole thing is framed by two
competing organizations
one is trying to learn more about the
creatures whereas the other is trying to
annihilate them
we are definitely looking forward to the
first trailer the release of godzilla vs
kong is on may 21
2021 on hbo max and in theaters
you